join our weekly Amazon giftcard giveaway
all you have to do is be subscribed to
our channel like this video and leave a
comment about today's topic we will
choose winners randomly from the
comments section hey guys the seventh
season finally arrived and its premiere
letter so speechless a theory that I
introduced to its a few months ago and
in my last video came true
Aryeh start where voters face to set up
a huge meeting that attended all
important phrase and killed every last
one of them with a poison which as I
said those foreshadowed back in the
fourth season while there are plenty of
important scenes that happened in this
episode which I will break down in the
upcoming days today I will break down
the recently released preview for the
second episode Daenerys was born on
Dragonstone valve a storm raged and for
this reason she's sometimes called the
near storm born storm born is also the
title the second episode of the seventh
season which is another title named
after Daenerys and her home as the
season premiere is named Dragonstone
preview starts with John Royce the Lord
of Runestone and the powerful Bannerman
of house Lorraine stating that the
Targaryen cannot be trusted
and as you probably guessed the queen of
dragons will send invitation to the king
in the north end other nodes and Lords
to come and meet her at Dragonstone
Daenerys is annotation along with Sam's
letter in which she states that there's
plenty of dragonglass on Dragonstone
island the lead-up severs and John's
known to live interval for Dragonstone
placed on with John and Daenerys so meet
for the very first time even though John
snows main intention will not be to meet
Daenerys but rather to collect as much
dragon glass as he can then we have a
shot of Circe's saying
the Mad King daughter will destroy the
realm the matte finish trying to even
the odds and she will try to persuade
other important people to support her
rather than the nearest Targaryen well
there will be a huge meeting in
Winterfell once again there will also be
a huge meeting in Dragonstone
as you can see Daenerys will have a huge
meeting in which you'll plan the
conquest of Westeros with her advisers
and allies in the main hole in the
castle of Dragonstone now we come to the
most exciting shot of this preview which
is the chateau fires dire wall Cimmeria
the shut official confirmed that
Caravelle finally reunited for direwolf
that you forced to leave in the very
first season that she was afraid for her
direwolf's well-being which was the
consequence of nemedia protecting aria
from the Prince Joffrey Baratheon by
biting Joffrey's arm now that we know
that aria will reunited for die role in
my opinion there's a high possibility
that this same direwolf will reunite
with Aria by saving her life this
prediction of mine is simply a result of
considering the jump Dolph mostly
appeared in crucial moments such as
saving the Lord commanders live by
whining at the door
saving Sam's life from a bite and giving
a chance to the Lord Commander to
destroy the white with fire helping to
kill the wildlings during the Battle of
Castle black and also defending John's
body with all of this being said I think
that the Mira's appearance will be
nothing less but glorious Namira will
appear and save Arya once again in
description for the second episode there
stated that Daenerys receives unexpected
visitor whom she probably meets in this
particular shot an unexpected visitor is
most likely no Sandra's we got to see
her in Dragonstone in the first official
trailer of the seventh season there's
also a shot of Jon Snow slamming
Littlefinger against the wall similar as
Ned did back in the first season but
let's hope Jon will not end up
manipulated and betrayed
let's hope Jon will learn from his
family's mistake as sense that pointed
out he should in today's episode there
are also a few shots of a huge fleet
battle that will result it a lot of
casualties for Denny's allies in the
following days I will surely bring you
numerous theories and predictions based
on the first episode of the seventh
season and as always let me know your
opinion about all of this in the comment
section down below I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and I hope to see in the next peace
you